let me tell you a little secret athletes
in America smoke weed shocking I know
marijuana is now legal for recreational
use in nine states and legal for
medicinal purposes in 29 of the sickest
states but it's still a banned substance
in three of the four major sports and
federally it's still illegal
yes Attorney General Jeff Sessions is
apparently saying that weed is quote
only slightly less awful than heroin
that's like saying a hug from the
Houston Rockets adorable bear mascot
clutch is only slightly less awful than
a punch in the face from an actual bear
now is the time to let a fleet smoke
weed if they want to I'm Dave shilling
and here's why
research suggests CBD the element of
cannabis but does not offer a high may
help with concussion recovery a US
government patent also says cannabinoids
have the potential to limit neurological
damage after trauma currently athletes
are prescribed highly addictive opioids
like percocet or vicodin for pain via
their own teams a 2011 study written by
researchers from Washington University
in st. Louis said that 71% of 336 former
NFL players reported misuse of opioids
during their time in the league studies
have shown cannabis is a safer less
addictive natural replacement for pain
killers what sounds better to you I try
to pour it all in your butt a little
push this is such a simple common-sense
thing that of course no one over the age
of 50 seems to understand unless their
name is Steve Kerr CBD may also help
with anxiety millions of Americans
suffer from anxiety without having to
also travel around the country every
other night to be clothesline by Isaiah
Thomas on national TV not only can we
help you improve your training and
assist in recovery it's fun I'd rather
light up in Jay after
championship then get the stinging
burning sensation of champagne why I
need it in my sensitive little eyeballs
so leave weed alone smoke em if you
gottem sparkling good brother just don't
operate a vehicle very sharp op next try
to solve a complex math problem or text
your wife or girlfriend will you do
[Music]